hello everybody I just wanted to take a
moment to thank you all so much for
doing everything you could have possibly
done more than I asked for to make my
channel something big in no time flat
we've hit over 500 subscribers I didn't
even think I'd get there in a week I was
prepared to get wait a month to get you
into a thousand subscribers and it looks
like we're gonna get there in a few days
so - thank you guys I got me some Mallos
oh you know what we're okay one Hey
chubby bunny I lost count in the madness
of me stuffing my face tasty though I
don't think you want to see this
however I'll show you now that was in my
mouth I uh I'll review the footage later
to see what I got up to but thank you
guys again my mallow covered fingers oh
yeah thank you guys so much I can't
thank you enough um especially well
thank you everyone equally I'm not
saying one more than another but some
people actually took the time to like
and favorite every single one of my
videos all 206 and I know that takes a
long time because I went through and did
the annotations in descriptions for all
of them and Africa ours to do so thank
you guys so much for putting in the
effort to making my channel something
big it's unbelievable
what you guys have done for me and I
can't thank you enough I hope this this
is a good enough gesture of my goodwill
towards you guys but thanks again thank
you and thank you everyone for watching
this video of ridiculousness and I will
see you in the next video bye bye